[Applause]
make up a mainstay for pop stars but at
this year's Brit Awards Jess Glynne made
a clear statement it's not needed to
look beautiful she's just one name
supporting a new campaign calling on
women and men to go makeup free in May
it officially launched at the bee bear
festival where people gathered to dance
discuss and do yoga the aim to promote
skin confidence and good mental health
we are not against beauty industry we
want to work with beauty industry to
provide different line of product
different marketing strategy even why
it's you when women look at the
advertising is empowering you know it
doesn't create self-doubt
for many the pressure to look a certain
way is perpetuated online and it can
cause anxiety 1/3 of teenagers spend at
least 3 hours a day on social media and
heavy users are three times more likely
to suffer with depression for
psychologists the young are most at risk
that's a message that is beyond just
taking off your makeup it's about sort
of embracing the authentic you not
trying to hide behind a mask and it's
not the makeup is bad right it's just
that to be able to be able to be
yourself and have the option of putting
on something and taking it off whereas
again if you have these idealistic
notions constantly fed to you you just
think you can only exist in one way the
hope is to change the perception of
makeup as necessary for many women
removing their makeup is a scary
challenge but the message of the
campaign is not that makeup is bad per
se just that wearing it is a choice and
that people can be beautiful and
confident without it mark sapanta is a
beauty blogger and drag queen for him
both makeup and social media can be
positive I started my youtube channel at
2011 2012 I was
scene 17 I'm 24 now and back then it
wasn't really a thing for guys to be
wearing makeup now I see everywhere I
see so many instagramers just showcasing
yourself in that sort of platform in
being brave enough shows to other people
shows that other guys that they can do
it themselves if they wish to do so the
cosmetic industry is worth billions of
pounds a year and beauty bloggers can be
paid thousands for just one post the
campaign simply asks for promotion of
beauty to be realistic Helen Ann Smith
Sky News